civiles huyendo de sus hogares ciudades
sitiadas y destrucción vuelven las
imágenes de guerra a afganistán y la
endémica violencia e inseguridad crónica
durante los últimos 20 años el mapa de
control del país ha sido un lienzo en
constante cambio pero ahora con la
retirada de las tropas de
estadounidenses y sus aliados llegando a
su fin no nuestra misión militar en
afganistán concluirá el 31 de agosto más
del 56% del territorio está en manos de
los talibanes desde la ofensiva lanzada
el 1 de mayo tras conquistar con
relativa facilidad las abandonadas zonas
rurales donde la presencia del gobierno
es muy reducida el grupo islamista se ha
hecho con el control de seis capitales
de provincias y están en enfrentamientos
en 112 ciudades mientras las desmorona
las fuerzas de seguridad afganas
intentan frenar los ataques en kandahar
la carga afortunadamente la situación de
seguridad en las provincias de kandahar
las cargas herat ha mejorado las fuerzas
de seguridad afganas están patrullando
las ciudades el enemigo ha sufrido
grandes pérdidas
para wang jianzhou desde los años 80 los
afganos han vivido en permanente guerra
con
reciente insurrección los talibanes han
sorprendido al no haber esperado la
retirada completa de las tropas
extranjeras una señal según apunta los
analistas de que se sienten fuertes
tanto el gobierno urbano los
observadores internacionales se muestran
pesimistas no sólo por el poder
armamentístico talibán sino por los
pactos con los señores de la guerra
locales que anticipan un avance mayor
del grupo los afganos tienen un dicho
los extranjeros tienen el reloj pero
nosotros tenemos el tiempo desde su
derrota en 2001 los talibanes han sido
conscientes de que las tropas
internacionales irían más pronto que
tarde
afganistán inicia así una guerra
infinita que tiene un solo perdedor la
población civil afgana